Wow - Gomez my name
boom ah welcome back to come down I have
no idea - [ __ ] - go I think I fell from
the scam oh yeah
alright investigate press readied random
boat there it is took my wife
Oh God I'll just follow this trace over
here and it ends suddenly no continues
what's going on in here it's kind of
creepy Wow anyone in here oh it's creepy
maybe I fell from this hell is that they
flying oh dude this guy skit ha ha
you're on Facebook no it's gonna take a
photo
god damn it and the trail was last
alright fine
let's go in here hey drugs
cool more morphine let's see if we can
find some friends random bud number two
there it is there it is gorgeous
so anything else well is the point of
all this
tell me tell me I don't know what you're
calling what the boot Buddha stop head
boot
stop stop stop stop good but butch
blockage ha ha ha ha that's what you get
[ __ ] that's right that's right the [ __ ]
are you doing get off me it's my house
not your house my hat oh cool I don't
know I had that feature so did you get
for hiding from me women
that was pointless maybe I should go
back or something
[ __ ] you walk so slow the thing is the
game keyboard it unbinds shift sprint
look unassigned no it's not on a side I
assign it three times now I can run holy
[ __ ]
so stupid alright maybe you should
follow his trail again
and did oh here we go alright time to
take photos do you want me to take
photos oh this this [ __ ] beep or
something there we go ha ha
works every time alright lady 10 min
this is an exact match to the AH gets
stuck in my beard
alright finger we need to I would if I
meet him but this part of the department
store is flooded his TV a woman I like
what hook shot try using your cast
hydrometer Oh
you start to get immediately producing
hydrogen sulfide huh I would sniff it
out just like I sniff your Virginia
alright
it's just a gas spectrum why can I'm
overhead whoa [ __ ] that clanks do not
move like that I don't like it
Jesus what name that don't make me shoot
you while you're in boot I didn't want
to use fruit on you man I did not want
to do it but I had to it's your pot cap
damn Jesus man I don't know about you
man I thought you were cool planks
[ __ ] off planks alright I guess we got
to go up here or some [ __ ]
anyone in here it's like wow how is
Hagrid whoa holy [ __ ] are you a vampire
bow to the face bow to the box ah which
one do you want which one Ram
ha ha ha ha ha ha such a get for being
homeless
ha it's your punishment all right what's
going on here oh I don't trust you one
second hey I let it wake up let's see if
she wakes up from this hey I told you to
wake up lazy woman knew it hey you got a
present for me cut and trust you either
whoa what the [ __ ] hey I got a mannequin
arm thing whoa what the [ __ ] did he go I
do I speak to your dread nice [ __ ] you
I shut off your boss breaks every time
yeah missed you man [ __ ] missed it
why did you leave me man I don't know
penny I don't know I just got chopping
mall and Doc good all right here's my
head ah all right who wants to [ __ ] with
me huh tell me how am I going
now walk here before oh it's in oh okay
I remember there was like a fire it's
kind of creepy it's getting a lot
creepier this game whoa
who's there Wow taeseop off got you back
come in come in hey how do you feel I
feel pretty good ten what Dad huh it is
drag with you woman someone out there
seriously can you die in the normal way
like everyone it what's out there back
in that all right exit hair Mountain
haha stupid [ __ ] gonna get killed
okay anyone here that I can actually
kill I'd be pretty cool Wow Wow cool
what's going on in here whoa
Wow Wow
whoa lamp it says Noel on it it's a joke
name huh I guess I gotta investigate
these whoa
Oh No
it's ripened time oh [ __ ] it's over here
here huh sorry for introducing into
trading I mean nice teddy
but yeah nice it's me just take fun of
you why I'm doing this I don't know
either man it's just a hobby maybe I'm
supposed
wow they look smaller looks like okay
let me get a good look on you
well maybe Y leg
what's wrong with the focus come on
focus man there we go God yes MA
beautiful couple
alright okay Kyle it's pretty weird I
think huh huh he's missing a finger too
I should be an FBI agent uh-huh
all right fine sorry sir I'll be on my
way in a second I'll just need to take
third of your gorgeous face you look
like a rat and then whatever told you
that all right hello that makes no sense
suggests righthand got it lady all right
sorry about this man that is not his
right hand there it is I knew it the
right finger thing I'm out of here
yes I'm super excited about it too this
guy's the match oh well he certainly
didn't kill himself and set it up this
night all right
one more photo and that would be ed oh
I'll just scan this finger pit in let me
shoot you with a laser sir thank you
hold still there we go and we are done
here thank you very much for comin yeah
I got dabit that is what is it what the
hell are you talking about lady huh oh
[ __ ] me did you read set me out
you [ __ ] Oh triangle right now whoa
whoa whoa did I hey I didn't know you
loved each other man I'm sorry I'm sorry
you don't have to kill me I won't tell
anyone you're gay I'm sorry [ __ ] me
actually don't please you really had to
what did you do to those man's balls
really huh the sad things what it's a
sad thing
awesome all right no I'm not I'm getting
good back all right secret done now a
doesn't work either
hello ah-ooh
[ __ ] you hey hey don't make me do it
don't make me do it don't make boot Oh
boot
I didn't want you to come to this but
boot has the power whatever everything
that's right but they will never it is
anyone else want to tango huh anyone
else want a piece a boot boot is
generous boot shares his fantasies with
you Santa what what it's from upstairs I
guess I gotta go upstairs then
oh sorry ah not right now lady I'm
surrounded by the cops
uh-huh each of the articles talks about
a serial no way serial killer that was
on your case huh seminal and I were
crossed huh huh you the clippings my own
black felt-tip Martin the only names
that were crossed out or the matchmaker
so that's the touch and now you can
cross off the match uh-huh
wait are you implying that there's
someone stalking serial killers huh so
what he goes around killing Kim and then
he marks off their name in his little
personal data cards no it does not but
it adds up and almost but yes whoa [ __ ]
hey
patty obvious all right it is shut good
time don't you dare come alive whoa
don't you dad I'm watching you man
what what what is that it smells nice
hey sorry about this sorry about this
cops is coming sorry about that sorry
whoops cops are coming
Oh exit door is conveniently open isn't
that lovely
oh [ __ ] me hey beautiful sky high air
mass mode to the face in slow motion F
pixel has gone up don't distract me from
boot [ __ ] are you doing go to the face
go to the face virgin face if your face
was in your ass then I will actually put
your fake alright oh [ __ ] No
all right we finish after I think a
friend is here like volution good
subscribe come Richard and I'll see you
next episode of camera whatever is
ironic that's really [ __ ] stay awesome
but I get her oh hey what's happened
whoa nice Dodge Santa I'm humping [ __ ]
yes are we doing this
[ __ ] you're sad I'm doing it alone with
pineapple [ __ ] yeah
the best winning pose ever